So here we have our function, inName.
It takes in a parameter called name, so when we take a name we want to call
trim, which removes the white space from the front and the back of that string.
So our string currently will look something like this, we can
see that this string doesn't have any differentiation between the first name and
the last name.
So we have to call a function called split, and we pass in the character or
string that we want to split the source string from.
So in this case, it's a space which occurs here between Sebastian and Thrun.
Now when we call split, it returns an array of Sebastian and
Thrun, our next line here prints out that to the console.
This next line, name one equals name one to
uppercase changes our last name to totally uppercase.
So in this array down here, we have name zero and
we have name one which has been turned into totally upper case.
This next line is a little bit tricky.
Let's take it piece by piece, name[0].slice(0,1).toUpperCase().
The .slice function takes in two parameters of where to start and
where to end in a string and creates a substring.
So for this one in name[0] right here it's starting at position 0.
It's converting that to upper case, which it already was,
but our function doesn't have a way of knowing that and then it appends it to,
to a slice starting at position one, and converting that string to lowercase.
If you don't pass in a second parameter, it goes to the end of the string.
So looking at this example again.
We'll start at position one and go all the way to the end where the n is.
So our last line takes those two values and appends them together.
It return to the other string, and our string becomes.
All done.